hey there welcome to con O'Brien needs a
friend joined by my two friends I
consider you friends oh that's nice no
it took a while um five years uh yes
15 is that how Sona how long have you
been with me you know I I actually just
messaged you recently because I found 15
years ago on December 3rd I found out I
got my job because it's my best friend
Christina's birthday and and I I emailed
you I was like she emailed me it was
very sweet and she said it was 15 years
ago that she met she was going to be my
brand new assistant cuz I was moving out
to Los Angeles uh to host a Tonight Show
for 40
years the plan went off without a hitch
um but uh I'll never forget you met me
we had the interview and then I you were
told that you were hired and then we met
at a coffee shop yeah on San Vicente in
Brentwood I remembered in the meeting
that that for some some reason you were
sitting on a couch that I think was a
very low couch and had a soft cushion so
people were asking me who' you end up
hiring I said oh it's this woman Sona
she seems really bright and I she's
highly
recommended um and so I hired her and
they're like well what what she like I
said she's got dark hair she's really
short cuz I just remember thinking you
were really short cuz you sunk into the
couch so then I meet you at this coffee
shop and you are tall yeah pretty tall I
mean but with your hair was was up you
had your hair bun up so made you over 8
and uh uh but you came in and I
remembered it Sona had a notebook and
she was writing everything I said down
very seriously and we had a professional
exchange it was for the last time it was
so
hilarious because and I will say I did
more to corrupt things immediately than
anyone you did all of it I did all my
con and stick and very quickly you said
I'm not going to listen to anything this
guy says nothing serious he's fool but I
always go back to that first time Sona
walks in um taller than I had remembered
that's the first thing it struck me
notebook writing everything down and
then on our own initiative because I was
moving my whole family uh out from New
York she made a book for me like a
professional
book that she had bound that said here's
what helpful things to know about LA and
it included uh when it first rains in La
there's a lot of sediment because it
doesn't rain regularly so drive more
carefully um the secret menu for In and
Out yeah no seriously no no seriously it
was filled and it was a book that you
could have published that you just made
on your own and I remembered thinking
this person is fantastic and then I
immediately corrupted you yeah and it
reminds me of on The
Simpsons uh I didn't write this joke but
someone wrote this joke where you know
Barney's really smart and he's studying
hard for the you know LSAT or something
he's just Barney and and then Homer keep
convinces him to have a drink of beer
and he has it and he immediately turns
into Barney and he's
like and you
see uh I'm
Barney oh well he's Homer I realized I
infected you with the Conan uh stupidity
and then that was all gone and then it
went from hey Sona you know when is my
car going to be out of my out of the
shop
boohoo con doesn't have his car fancy
talk show host won't have a way to no
Sona I know I'm just curious when it's
going to be out so I know that I don't
have to take an
Uber
Uber Corban needs a friend is brought to
you by the Kia ev9 and Sirius XM Sony
you remember we talked about the Kia ev9
and um we finally got to see it I went
down and looked at it beautiful uh well
first of all the color was gorgeous it's
just nice blue it's got this very
spacious third row I love a third row
I'm a large fellow as you know I'm 6'4
all muscle okay well that's debatable I
was very comfortable I really enjoyed it
and you know the plan the plan is to
have my assistant who took over for you
because you weren't working out David um
well you know what I mean you're goofing
around a lot David came in and David
you're going to run some errands me in
the Kia ev9 I'm excited it's a good-look
car and you and I sat in it for a second
it felt very comfortable oh so much
space Here's a little plus I want to add
SiriusXM offers a three-month trial
subscription to all equipped Kia
vehicles SiriusXM provides access to
over 165 plus channels in the vehicle to
listen to AdFree Music Plus sports news
comedy and more including fan favorite
con O'Brien radio on channel 104 I'm
going to send you out right you're going
to go out in the ev9 and uh you're going
to do some errands for me great just
enjoy this car you're a young guy this
is a fine fine car okay I'm not saying
that you don't deserve to drive a car
this nice but I am saying that that's
exactly what there it is the allnew all
electric 3 row Kia ev9 visit kia.com ev9
to learn more kia.com ev9 Kia movement
that inspires I think you're giving me
too much credit I think your kids
actually said the most accurate thing
which is you uh you melted half my brain
and then they you said well what H what
was wrong with her first half of her
brain and they were like it was already
melted this my kids when they were
little I said something about Sona and
they went you melted half her brain and
these are little kids and I said what
about the first half and they went that
was already melted I'm like I think that
is the best
description of my relationship with Sona
now Gorly came to me more fully formed
as as a human being and tried to damage
you uh but you seem more resistant oh
I'm pre-damaged you're pre-damaged yeah
I think but you seem like you have it
together oh no no falling apart okay
yeah W you make falling apart look
pretty good you clean up real nice you
know I think so yeah it's it is it is
funny how uh these little memories come
along and you you time travel back to oh
right uh I was an adult who was a TV
host who was meeting a assistant and we
were a professional yeah seconds before
it all went to cuckoo town you got in
just just in time I I I want someone to
do a deep dive of people before they met
you and after they met you and how how
much you ruined them well you know
what's been amazing is my wife my my
wife is uh just so Liza is so Adept at
parrying my madness and hand you know
handling it and you know that thing I do
where I'm just saying crazy things and
son will say what'd you say that for and
I'll say don't let him bother you I talk
about myself in the third person and I
managed to get people around me going
what do you mean him and I go he's just
be who and I'll be like Conan Conan's
just in one of those it's just Conan
doing his Conan thing and they're like
no you're it's so great because I do
that around uh Liza and she's like uhhuh
okay so anyway she's completely UNF she
is not having it it's not
you make all of us
unhirable and you do I think you do it
on purpose like I don't Blake can't work
anywhere else no no I've been ruined yes
nether none of us can work anywhere else
no Eduardo Eduardo uh could still hasn't
been ruined yet Eduardo I think could
still and you will soon work someplace
else because I know you have that look
of someone who's like I'm out of here
but Eduardo I haven't ruined you yet
right no I don't think so yeah but you
are very comfortable giving me tons of
constantly now I am thanks to Sona
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's my legacy I
think you came in the other day and just
immediately attacked me for something I
flipped off anyone more times than
my no I'll see I'll see Ardo like
walking down the street and I low my
window go like Edo and he flips me off
like wow that guy hates don't talk to me
in public
what's it like to work for
someone you're like scared of I would
never know that I know I learned that
too oh no no one has uh anyone who knows
me is immediately unafraid to just to
tell me exactly what they think of me I
think it's it's not that I don't want to
speak for you two but it's not that you
feel like powerful it's more a defense
mechanism of like I you have to put up
your walls with this guy you have to
defend yourself at this guy by the way
is out of control this guy is well this
guy Conan uh and I've noticed t with him
I think he's I think he's I think he's
insanely talented this is mad no no he's
ins look I'm saying this as a I've
watched him for a while he's crazy off
the charts um wrap it up dick
face probably means Conan that's the but
you know what to Matt's credit that's
how you have to deal with Conan because
he's he he's what he's what he's a once
in a hundred-year talent but then he
gets off the rails and this is how he
has to be dealt with so I what you guys
are doing is
perfect say you are a once in a 100
years
something